let's do a survey about how we would
measure the volume of fluids under under
u.s customary units so the smallest
volume of fluid that you'll hear people
talk about and this will often be in
cooking recipes or something like this
you'll talk about someone you'll talk
about a teaspoon
a teaspoon and most of us have teaspoons
that are roughly the size of a teaspoon
in our cupboards someplace so this
recipe might call for a teaspoon of
sugar or teaspoon of salt or a teaspoon
of oil and you've seen what it looks
like but those are the smaller spoons
that you might have in your in your
cabinets in your kitchen at home so this
might be a teaspoon right over here
now if you were to take three teaspoons
together you have something else that
you would probably have in your cabinets
so if we multiply
this volume so let's say this is right
over here is a teaspoon this right over
here is a teaspoon of some substance if
you multiply that by 3 then you get to
the tablespoon
table tablespoon
so three teaspoons equal one tablespoon
so a tablespoon is going to be a little
bit bigger so tablespoon might look like
this and these are the bigger these tend
to be about the size of the larger
spoons that you have in your cupboard so
a tablespoon just like that so if you
have three times the fluid you get to a
tablespoon
now if you take two tablespoons
you take two tablespoons put them
together
then you get to the ounce and i have to
be careful here you get to the fluid
ounce
the fluid ounce and the us customary
units they aren't designed to be super
super clear because you also have the
ounce as a measure of weight you have
the ounce
you have the ounce that is a measure of
weight which is equal to 1 16
of a pound and now you have a fluid
ounce which you could either view as 2
tablespoons or as we'll see 1 8 of a cup
now you might say well why are they both
called ounces what's the relationship
between the two well there is a a
somewhat of a relationship between the
two if you took a little bit over an
ounce of water so a weight of ounce of
water a little slightly over an ounce of
water that volume is going to be about a
fluid ounce so an ounce of water and a
fluid ounce a fluid ounce of water an
ounce of water and weight
and a fluid ounce of water and volume
are very very very close although they
aren't exactly the same thing
now if you were to take and you know if
you think about what would you measure
here we already talked about recipes and
teaspoon tablespoon fluid ounce you
might be thinking about how much
medicine maybe someone might take maybe
they need to take two tablespoons which
would be equivalent to a fluid ounce now
if you take eight fluid ounces and put
them together so let me make let me draw
a fluid ounce here just look like we
keep we just so we still have drawings
so you can imagine some medicines have a
little cap on the top that you could put
the medicine in
so
that might be if you do two tablespoons
in it maybe that'll be the fluid ounce
now if you take eight fluid ounces if
you take 8 fluid ounces
then you get to a cup
and many of us have this in our kitchens
we have a measuring cup that will
measure exactly a cup and you might have
a recipe for pancakes that say hey put a
cup of flour in there put a cup of flour
in there
and also a lot of the cups that you have
in your house might be around might be
around the size of a cup if you look at
say a can of soda that you're probably
familiar with
a can of soda the typical can of soda is
12 ounces not eight ounces so typical
can of soda is a cup and a half we see
that a cup is eight fluid ounces a
typical can of soda is 12 fluid ounces
so it is equivalent it is equivalent to
a cup and a half let me make sure this
looks like a can of some kind so this if
this was 12 ounces
this is 12 ounces this is one and one
half
cups but it gets you a sense of how much
fluid volume a cup actually is
now if we were to take two cups
if you were to take two cups now you're
dealing with now you're dealing with a
pint and so you might have seen pints a
pint might look
sometimes they're in these kind of small
cartons so a pint might look something
like
this in a carton that looks more like a
house but i think hopefully you get the
the picture that this is intended to be
a carton of some kind
so you have something like that and so
the pint it's two cups and so let's say
this is the fluid inside of it let's say
this was transparent you might see it
there or if you have like a very large
mug that might be the size of a pint so
if you have a kind of a very large
a very large mug like this
so
my best attempt at drawing a large mug
this might be roughly
roughly equal
roughly equal to a pint so let me put
some fluid in here
so there you go there's my large mug
it's got a pint now if you take two
pints
you take two pints
now you're dealing with a quart
and you might have found yourself going
to your local convenience store and
buying a quart of milk
a quart of milk those are kind of
those
longer
those longer but still kind of skinny
skinny looking
so it might look it might look something
like this i'm trying to draw make a
carton
of a quart of milk and then finally if
you were to take if you were to take
four quarts together you get to a gallon
so
you take four quarts together so times
four
you get to a gallon you get to a gallon
so we're most familiar with a
gallon of milk so let me see if i can
draw a gallon of milk here my best
attempt
at well
i'm sure someone could draw a better
gallon of milk here but you've it's at
least in the u.s it tends to be one of
the most typical ways that they sell
they sell milk and it has oftentimes a
little red or orange thing right on top
there so a gallon of milk so just to
review things and if we want to think
you know right here i just multiplied
from the smaller unit to the larger one
but if you want to think about
everything in terms of ounces that's one
way to think about it
a cup a cup right over here is equal to
so this is going to a cup is going to be
equal to 8 ounces eight ounces is equal
to a cup if you multiply that by two
then you get to 16 ounces
is equal to a pint
if you multiply that by two you get 32
ounces
ounces is equal to a quart and if you
multiply that times 4
you get 30 times 4 is 120
plus
8. you get 128
128 ounces
per gallon and so next time you go buy
something in the supermarket i encourage
you to look at it how it's being
measured and you'll see oftentimes you
might buy a quart of milk but they'll
also say that this is a 32 ounce
container in this context they're
talking about fluid ounces